[Musique]
à istanbul à bord des bateaux qui
sillonnent le détroit du bosphore à flux
des touristes venus de tout le monde
arabe
en l'espace d'un an leur nombre devrait
doubler
[Musique]
bonjour à tous sur le côté gauche du
bateau vous avez la rive européenne et
sur la droite du bateau c'est la rive
asiatique
ces visiteurs tunisiens écoute poliment
les commentaires historiques qui rythme
le parcours mais ce qui les intéresse le
plus ce ne sont pas les palais des
sultans cette vie là c'est le décor de
nour une des séries télévisées turques
eux qui cartonne en tunisie mme des
décors de rêve des héros glamours des
jeunes femmes émancipées vous ils voient
que j'ai de nouveau les tentures et l'a
ouvert ont fait bondir du valais on
tient pas
on dirait le rhdp
les tunisiens continuent à fêter leur
révolution mais s'interroge sur la suite
quel modèle politique adoptée comment
relancer leur économie
lamia y même son prof de sciences en
tunisie la sultana met au pied des
mosquées du xvème siècle elle
s'interroge
les turcs ont peut être trouvé la bonne
combinaison
même si en tunisie d'avoir les
traditions la religion la civilisation
islamique
en même temps avec un progrès économique
avec un progrès
toute spéciale noah ça donc je trouve
que c'est bien c'est très bien faire du
[Rires]
changement de registre séquence shopping
dans le plus grand centre commercial
d'europe sur cinq niveaux l'équivalent
de 50 terrains de foot en surfaces
commerciales avec toutes les marques à
la mode
[Musique]
ça pourrait être une image une des
images de la réussite économique turque
ça
ce mariage réussi entre islam politique
démocratie et croissance a été accompli
par la cape et le parti islamo
conservateur du premier ministre erdogan
au pouvoir depuis 2003 il briguera un
troisième mandat aux élections
législatives de juin et se pose
aujourd'hui en leaders du monde musulman
si nous désirons la démocratie la
prospérité la justice et la liberté pour
nous nous le souhaitons également pour
les peuples frères pour comprendre ce
modèle turc direction est saine l'air un
arrondissement populaire du nord ouest
d'istanbul où la cape et règne depuis
2003 avec plus de 60% des voix aux
élections
l'équipe locale du parti a des objectifs
ambitieux notre premier ministre a fixé
comme objectif que la turquie devienne
la sixième puissance économique mondiale
en 2023 pour le centième anniversaire de
la république turque
grâce à un maillage serré du quartier
ils ont recruté dans leur partie 20% des
450 mille habitants en âge de voter
les points qui clignotent
ce sont les bureaux du parti entoure
nous en avons 28 c'est une organisation
quasi militaire
oui ici c'est l'état major l'esprit est
amateur mais on travaille comme des
professionnels
ce matin-là umut et de sortie pour une
petite visite de terrain pré électoral
avec mes maîtres cox ou le maire lui
aussi à cap et au jour ma soeur comment
allez vous au menu serrage de main
petits services rendus aux habitants et
surtout l'écoutent
la cape et à la confiance des citoyens
car ils prétendent ne rien négliger de
leurs problèmes quotidiens
il ya trop de circulation en bas de chez
moi trop de voitures qu'ils gardent ça
nous gêne youssouf bien noté on va
s'occuper de ça bonjour les amis comment
ça va dans le quartier moi je n'y suis
pas du coin
dans la principale artère commerçante
les femmes du parti sont à l'affût pour
recruter les ménagères l'adhésion est
gratuite
il ne faudra pas manquer de pin 6 il
faudra en demander un depuis ce matin on
a fait 300 nouvelles adhésions
on va les rentrées dans nos registres ce
soir je suis contente du service qu'ils
offrent
et on aime beaucoup notre premier
ministre on espère qu'il va remporter
les élections si dieu le veut
le maire des scènes l'air n'hésite pas à
faire les sorties d'école pour enrôler
de futurs militants avec des ficelles
parfois un peu grosse il a même mis sa
photo dans les cahiers distribuer aux
écoliers il a aussi fait construire un
centre culturel un centre de formation
pour les femmes et ce parc tout neuf
de quoi assurer aux parties de mon
résultat à la hauteur de la popularité
du premier ministre
je peux vous dire que où qu'il aille au
moyen-orient notre premier ministre
pourrait être élue avec 75 ou 80 % des
voix dans ce cas cela veut dire que
notre modèle est transposable
ce succès il est d'abord liée à l'essor
de l'économie turque
aujourd'hui à la 15e place dans le monde
l'industrie est constitué de petites
entreprises comme celle de serdar qui
fabrique des systèmes d'échafaudage avec
9 % de progression en 2010 la croissance
turque n'est dépassée que par la chine
et l'argentine
au fur et à mesure qu'ils tombent ou
s'agrandit vers l'extérieur il ya
beaucoup de nouveaux quartiers qui
émergent les bâtiments que vous voyez
ici on a travaillé dessus
cerda réalise 15 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et exporte des
échafaudages dans 25 pays
ça c'est en libye un de mes grands
projets là c'est à bakou en azerbaïdjan
une usine pour produire du coca cola ce
coin là on va regarder où sa dot être
exporté à l'étranger
ces produits s'ils doivent partir en
irak les milieux d'affaires turcs et les
petits entrepreneurs comme serdar sont
ceux qui ont le plus profité des années
erdogan
ils ont soutenu la politique libérale de
la cap et
6 6 2
pour maintenir l'emploi sérieusement les
industries sont très bien soutenu par
l'état avec un seul parti au pouvoir la
cape et le gouvernement une marge de
manoeuvre considérable
le fait de pouvoir prendre des décisions
rapidement ça permet d'influer très vite
sur l'économie le business fait donc bon
ménage avec l'islam modéré de la cap et
et dans chaque nouveau quartier une
mosquée flambant neuve sort de terre
mais ici tout ce qui a trait à la
religion à commencer par les mosquées et
sous le strict contrôle de l'état le
modèle turc
c'est aussi un modèle laïque instauré
avec la république en 1924 retour est
saine l'air avec umut à l'heure de la
prière de la mi-journée pour une
rencontre avec l'imam du quartier avant
d'officier il est en costume cravate
on vient de la même ville lui les
politiciens mais moi j'ai déjà terminé
ma carrière
non non non ça se passe pas si vide que
ça
les imams ne parte en retraite si
facilement ils sont toujours en mission
en mission pour allah mais aussi pour
l'état le système laïc à la turquie est
très particulier pas de séparation comme
en france entre état et religion ici la
religion est sous l'autorité de l'état
les 70000 imams turcs sont tous
fonctionnaires formés et nommé par
l'état
elise tous les mêmes prêche dictée par
l'administration centrale
chaque semaine les ouzbeks les prêches
ne sont envoyés par le directorat des
affaires religieuses dans ce classeur je
garde les prêches des quatre dernières
années
nous sommes obligés de lire ses prêches
là et l'étape vérifier que cela a été
fait
[Musique]
ankara la capitale petite visite guidée
du diyanet le directorat des affaires
religieuses il y à mille fonctionnaires
qui travaillent si sion et ça c'est le
bureau des publications
cette administration très particulière
placé sous l'autorité directe du premier
ministre gère tous les aspects de la vie
religieuse du pays
là on reçoit les inscriptions et on
s'occupe des réservations cela va de
l'organisation du pèlerinage à la mecque
à la rédaction des prêches il ya même un
centre d'appels qui répondent chaque
jour à plusieurs centaines de questions
sur la pratique religieuse
vous avez quel âge vous êtes en mesure
de pratiquer l jeunes en général ce sont
des questions sur la prière les
conditions et les principes de la
religion
le pèlerinage l'aumône il y à des
questions sur le sacrifice des moutons
par exemple il ya une manière de les
tuer par choc électrique
est-ce que c'est conforme à la religion
ou pas
depuis qu'ils sont au pouvoir les
démocrates musulmans de la cap et non
pas toucher à ce système de tutelle de
l'état sur les mosquées mais cela
pourrait bien changer
il projette d'importantes réformes
constitutionnelles après les élections
de juin selon mon opinion il faut que
l'état cesse de se mêler de la religion
je pense qu'il faudra supprimer le
diyanet dans un avenir proche
le gouvernement à cap et a déjà réformé
le champ religieux en s'attaquant à la
question du voile interdit dans la
fonction publique où l'armée ils ont
obtenu qu'il soit désormais tolérée dans
l'enseignement supérieur
ce qui fait que chez les vendeuses de
foulards des scènes l'air le maire aka
paix est plutôt bien accueillie nous on
est très contentes
ok mais si vous ne votez pas pour la cap
et moi je viendrai fermer la boutique
mais nous on vote pour la cape est
depuis des années et là vous me direz
ainsi elle veut pas pour nous revenez
plus tard on vous dira ça le port du
foulard est beaucoup mieux tolérés
maintenant on peut passer les concours
universitaire avec le voile c'est très
important c'est un pays plus libre
qu'avant c'est mieux qu'avant mais les
libertés ne sont pas encore acquises
pour tous au pays des néo islamistes de
la cap et même si une réforme
progressivement le modèle laïque
autoritaire mis en place en 1924
certaines mauvaises habitudes sont
restés
une soixantaine de journalistes sont en
prison la plupart sont accusés de faire
partie d'un complot militaire qui visait
à renverser le gouvernement islamiste
le 3 mars dernier à 7 heures du matin
l'appartement de ahmed et yange à chuck
est investi par une dizaine de policiers
journaliste et écrivain ahmed choc
séjourne depuis en prison il était dans
le collimateur de la police sur laquelle
ils enquêtaient je te bouquetins ils ont
fouillé tout l'appartement ils ont sorti
tous les livres et les ont feuilleté un
par un ils ont regardé partout même dans
la chambre de notre enfant ils nous ont
pris 450 cd même les cd de musique
les dessins animés de notre fille et les
cd avec nos photos privées
c'est comme si j'avais été violée
ahmed sheikh écrivait un livre sur le
noyautage de la police par une confrérie
musulmane
il a été arrêté avant même la
publication son ouvrage circulent
aujourd'hui sur internet en détenir
simplement une copie c'est s'exposer à
une arrestation dans la rédaction du
quotidien radikal
les journalistes font de plus en plus
attention à ce qu'ils écrivent hertault
groupe mas viol ou ancien chef des
informations à une quinzaine de procès
sur le dos un de ses derniers papiers
une interview du chef rebelle kurde
mourad karayilan lui vaut d'être accusé
de violation de la loi contre le
terrorisme
les journalistes qui savent que
critiquer le gouvernement va leur poser
des problèmes
évite de le faire la dimension
dangereuse dans tout ça c'est qu'il ya
une sorte d'autocensure qui émergent
il y à des procès contre environ un
millier de journalistes à cause de 4000
articles qu'ils ont écrit un système qui
est basée sur la non existence du droit
ne peut pas s'appeler une démocratie
des journalistes sous pression des
minorités comme les kurdes dont les
droits ne sont pas toujours respectés
même s'il inspire des pays du monde
arabe sur la voie du changement comme la
tunisie le modèle turc a ses limites
[Musique]